our guest today is a very talented actor
who is making his broadway debut in the
pulitzer prize-winning new musical
a strange loop please welcome to the
show jaquail spy me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey y'all
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you for being my very first guest
thank you for having me
welcome jakewell thank you amber i want
to be transparent about why you're here
okay okay i wanted my first guest to be
special and you are one of the most
talented people i could think of you are
a true performers performer to come onto
broadway in the way that you did and
leave such a big mark after only one
show is magnificent you are a perfect
baby and i love you
but for people who haven't seen it tell
us what the show is about okay so if you
haven't seen it a strange loop follows
usher who is a musical theater writer in
new york city but by day he's an usher
uh and uh usher in a broad way um
theater and it's about him trying to
write a musical that makes him happy and
that tells the story he wants to tell
and it follows his thoughts which are
played by six other phenomenal actors
and it's a day in the life of someone
who's fat
black queer and an artist in new york
city
it's
heaven
sweet baby jaquille
you grew up watching musicals and
singing in church and then you started
performing now when did you first see
this show and know that you could do it
like how did you first come to it
never seen the show okay fun fact never
seen the show
listen to the cast album
and uh i fell in love with it and i was
like i just would love to be a part of
something like this
and i didn't know i could do it until i
did it in in dc
uh we started there out of town and then
of course we came back to new york but
it wasn't until that first show in front
of people it was like so that's why
y'all cast me
that's why y'all gave me that job
okay yeah you
were
perfect oh my god you got to give me
your phone number after this so every
time i think of it i can go oh my god
and my favorite thing was this and this
and this
i'll never stop no
sweet baby jay in one song your
character usher sings the lyric big
black queer ass american broadway show
which both describes the musical and a
new perspective that broadway is not
used to seeing now do you think that
that unique voice is one of the reasons
that people are loving it absolutely
absolutely i feel like
broadway was telling the same story in a
different musical
for pretty much years and we weren't
hearing the truth about what life is
like for
real people i feel like everybody on the
broadway stage is perfect like just
perfect body perfect teeth perfect voice
um or what people assume is perfect and
a strange loop follows a character who
is fat
and he's very black
and he's very gay
um and it's just it's a real life story
about a real person and we don't get
that often broadway can be very fake
um
and i think that gets a little tiring
when you keep seeing these false ideas
of what real life is like
that is
yeah
it's five million percent true
[Music]
it's just like
when you see it
you know it's like
wow
i have never seen anything like this
but
i i lived it you know it's like it's
it's everything
it's brand new but it's also home
if that makes sense yeah yeah it's it's
beautiful
sweet little pumpkin
your performance in this show is
incredible and i couldn't stop thinking
about how much you were doing you were
on stage for nearly the entire show and
you're singing and dancing so how do you
take care of your voice and yourself
like i do it by drinking a lot of
margaritas how do you do it
well
i do it by drinking no margaritas that's
right my baby has a fake margarita so
you better leave him alone
we've been living you know a sober life
since playing this role because you have
to uh eight shows a week is a lot like
you said i don't really leave the stage
um so i try my best to actually not
speak uh before the show or sing before
the show
uh and it's hard because i'm loud y'all
so i'm living a very silent life in one
of the loudest cities in the world uh
and that's a little difficult but we
learning we are justin um and then i
have like little things that get me
through the show like i don't drink
regular water it's either coconut water
it's pineapple juice or it's lemon water
and it helps me sing the score and get
through so it's just little tricks in
there pineapple juice pineapple write it
down broadway secrets pineapple juice
for real pineapple juice so every
morning when i have pineapple juice
i'm a broadway star broadway you're a
broadway star you broadway star amber
may i have a mai tai i'm a broadway star
um
do you feel like a star
ah you know it's crazy i feel like i've
always felt like a star
um
and i and i don't and i don't want that
to sound
arrogant but i think that especially for
me i've lived in a world where anything
about me is not acceptable
and the last thing i wanted to do was go
home look in the mirror and not like
myself
to go outside to people who also did not
like me and it's like somebody got to be
rooting for me
and if it ain't gonna be y'all it's damn
sure don't be me
um
so
you know i kinda i kinda had to live
life like a star to almost make myself
believe that you are somebody you
deserve to be listened to and you
deserve to take up space
i'm
going to record that and play it back to
myself when i'm feeling a little down
okay look this is going to be a few
rapid fire questions oh [ __ ] are you
emotionally prepared
let's try amber okay
now people want to get to know you you
know and people want to get to know your
stance on important issues so that's why
we're going to dig a little deeper okay
sweet baby all right now okay
you're doing dream girls which part do
you choose larelle dina or effie
i'ma choose dina
and here's why oh
[Applause]
so
dina starts off she's like the
background singer for effie she says
little innocent girl it's like i don't
want to sing lee
and then we watch her
turn into like this pop diva who just
owns the world and learns her worth and
that's just such a nice character to
watch grow and also she ain't got to do
too much and i'm in a show right now
where i have to do a hell of a lot so
i'm thinking of tracks where it's like
she just stands there she's cute she
sings her little song and her cute
little dress and she goes
home i like that i like that answer
unfortunately the correct answer was
laurel now here's the second question
don't have the vocal range
mary kill
fanny bryce
elphaba or little orphan annie mary kell
it's a tough i'm here asking you the
tough questions
mary kill okay elphaba fanny brice
little orphanage so just based off of
ages i'm a kill little orphan you have
to you got no choice
sorry
um
okay so i recently saw funny girl for
the first time yeah and in the show
she pretty much falls in love with a guy
and gives her all her money him all her
money so i'mma marry her
uh because i never got to work again
yeah uh and i think i'm just gonna
i'm gonna have to alphabet
okay and all white school is doing a
show all right it's all white middle
school in wisconsin they're doing a show
would you rather the show be porgy and
bess
once on this island or a raisin in the
sun
[Applause]
you know what
i think i'm gonna go for porgy and bess
yes i think i want the blackest show
because even once on this island they're
like it's not about race it's about
wealth and being poor but with porgy and
bess it's about black folk
so i want to see how these white babies
play
black folk going through hell but
singing beautiful opera
you're absolutely right that's perfect
answer
you guys do close by me everybody i love
him he's my perfect sweetheart a
stranger
is playing now at the lyceum theater go
see it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you